all right good evening my name is
lieutenant richard
r-i-c-h-a-r-d myers m-u-y-e-r-s
and i'm a lieutenant in the homicide sex
crimes bureau i'm here this evening to
give you the preliminary details of a
homicide that we are investigating in
the 6900 block
of menden lane in las vegas nevada
the preliminary details are that at
approximately 2 40 p.m
the lvmpd dispatch center received a 911
call
reference gunshots being fired in the
6900 block of
menden lane upon the arrival of our
patrol units
they located an adult male suffering
from gunshot wounds
medical personnel were requested
responded and pronounced that subject
deceased at the scene
at this time these are the preliminary
details that i can give you
as always the coroner will provide you
more details on our decedents
and we're asking anybody anybody with
information to contact
lvmpd homicide or through crime stoppers
and as always with crime stoppers
information leading to an arrest and
conviction may have reward money
attached to it
and with that i'll take a couple of
questions
it is outside no further questions
i'm sorry again as i said it's a
preliminary investigation right now is
where we're at we don't have anything to
substantiate any information regarding a
carjacking
any description on the person that was
injured no ma'am right now it's an adult
male that's all i'm going to
talk it's that subject was covered by
medical personnel and i have not been
able to confirm
whether what their ethnicity is
i don't have that they want more than
one
we don't know at this point again it's a
preliminary investigation the details
i've given you is what we know at this
time
all right thank you one more time
the rope thank you very much for that
question we're asking residents in the
area
obviously to talk to our marked patrol
units and we'll get them into their
house
the area specifically in front that we
have taped off will be closed for the
next couple of hours that's a great
question thank you